Let's look at identifying
duplicate records in ULTIRX.
We're going to start with a dataset
that has names and phone numbers in it.
Phone numbers can move from
one person to the next and
datasets can lag in terms of updating
new phone numbers to the right people.
So in this dataset, it would be nice
to know which phone numbers have
been associated with
more than one person.
One way we can do this is
to use the summarize tool.
When we add the summarize tool,
we highlight the phone field,
select add and group by.
When we run ULTRIX, we get a unique
list of the phone numbers.
If we look in the messages, we can
see that 14 records were summarized
to 11 groups, so
we know that there are duplicates.
To expose which phone number have
duplicates, we can go back to
the summarize tool, highlight the phone
field, go to add, and select count.
After we run the workflow, it will
show the count of the records for
each phone number, and which phone
numbers are in the data multiple times.
If we want to see the names
associated with these phone numbers,
we could add this as an additional field
in the summarize tool by selecting
contact, add, string, and concatenate.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
The result is a list of
names separated by commas.
If we had thousands or
millions of records, and
we wanted to identify the duplicates,
we may just want to filter
out the duplicates from the list and
review that list.
To do that we add the filter
tool after the summarize.
We select the count field,
and say greater than one.
Out of the true side is a list where
there was the same phone number for
more than one record.
There's another way that you can
find duplicates in your data though.
The unique tool does exactly this, but
it pulls through all of
the fields in your data.
We select the unique tool from
the preparation category.
Connect it to the input text, and
choose the phone number as the field
that we're going to
identify duplicates for.
Run the workflow.
On the U side are all of the records
that are unique records.
And on the duplicate side are the three
records that are duplicates
of records on the unique side.